NARRATOR: May 4th, 2015.
A tourist visiting the ancient
pyramid complex of Teotihuacan
takes a photograph featuring
the Pyramid of the Sun.
He thinks nothing of
it, until he later
reviews the photo and
notices two strange objects
hovering over the pyramid.
Upon closer examination,
they appear to be
silver, disk-shaped craft.
What's strange about
the two UFOs photographed
above the Pyramid of
the Sun at Teotihuacan
is that only 10 seconds later,
a second photograph was taken,
and those two objects were gone.
So clearly we are not talking
about Mylar balloons here.
There is nothing floating
in the sky anymore,
and if they would have
been Mylar balloons,
well, they don't move that
fast to just disappear.
There has been a long
history of UFO sightings
and unusual events
in Teotihuacan,
particularly around
the pyramids,
which perhaps are
somehow attracting
UFOs and extraterrestrials.
NARRATOR: Is there more
going on at Teotihuacan
than archaeologists realize?
Could there be secrets about
our extraterrestrial past
left for us to discover
at this ancient city?
At Teotihuacan, so far
only 10% has been excavated.
That means there's 90%
that remains to be dug up.
How much more is
there at the site?
We have no idea,
but we have to ask,
if we continue and press on,
might we find the artifacts,
the components, to start
to put the pieces together,
and perhaps lead us to a
much clearer concept of who
these beings were
who built this.
DAVID CHILDRESS: We don't
know what they will find
in the future, but I
suspect they'll make
some startling discoveries.
There's many things in our past
that we just don't understand,
but it's possible
that the answers--
some of them-- are
at Teotihuacan.